in June it was revealed that born writer
tony gilroy had been brought on to the
production of the upcoming Star Wars
spin-off rogue one to assist with the
film's extensive reshoots it's now been
reported that Gilroy has remained on the
film and is playing a major part in its
editing I'm Lucy and welcome to your
fill in the gap gamespot news update
according to The Hollywood Reporter
while director Gareth Edwards remains
heavily involved Gilroy has been
empowered to take the lead in the
post-production process the cite sources
stressed that the two filmmakers are
working together with Gilroy performing
a similar role during a production of
Edwards 2014 blockbuster Godzilla The
Hollywood Reporter also states that the
robe Juan reshoots have now been
completed and were designed to tackle a
number of issues including the film's
ending sources at Disney had previously
denied that the reshoots were for
anything major in June entertainment
weekly quoted one source who stated the
changes have everything to do with
clarity and character development and
all take place as insert within scenes
we've already shot are you going to see
rogue one when it hits theaters on
December 16th are you apprehensive about
the reshoots let me know in the comments
below or come find me on Twitter I'm at
Lucy James games the more on Star Wars
make sure you head over to youtube com
at / gamespot